Nos piden simplificar "m" al cubo,
elevado al cuadrado
dividido entre "mx" cúbica
y eso elevado a la cuarta,
y nos dicen,
expresa tu respuesta en forma exponencial.
Nos indican que "m" es distinto de 0
y "x" es distinto de 0,
pues si "m" o "n" fueran iguales a 0,
el denominador sería 0
y la expresión no estaría definida,
por eso nos dan esta restricción de aquí,
de que ninguna de ellas puede ser 0.
Tratemos entonces de simplificar esto,
para empezar lo voy a reescribir,
el numerador es "m" al cubo
elevado al cuadrado,
y el denominador es...
voy a usar un color distinto...
El denominador es
"m" por "x" elevado al cubo
y eso elevado a la cuarta.
Ahora trabajemos con estos de manera independiente,
¿Qué resulta de elevar "m" al cubo
y luego elevarlo al cuadrado?
Bien, si elevas algo al cubo
y después lo elevas al cuadrado,
eso va a ser igual... lo voy a poner por acá...
esto es "m" a la 3 por 2,
"m" a la 3 por 2
ó "m" elevado a la sexta potencia.
Elevamos "m" al cubo y eso lo elevamos al cuadrado, pues si te fijas bien esta expresión...
déjame ponerlo aquí, al lado...
Si tenemos "m" al cubo elevado al cuadrado
y aquí no hay ningún tipo de magia,
es simplemente matemática.
Veamos, esto sería "m" al cubo
multiplicado por sí mismo otra vez,
por "m" al cubo
y aquí tienes 2 veces el exponente 3,
si fuera "m" al cubo a la cuarta, entonces estarías multiplicando 4 veces el exponente 3,
es por eso que esto es "m" a la 3 por 2.
Así es que en el numerador tenemos "m" a la sexta
y en el denominador tenemos "m" por "x" al cubo,
elevado a la cuarta potencia.
En general cuando tienes el producto de 2 números elevado a una potencia,
puedes elevar cada uno de esos números a la potencia,
y después hacer el producto,
por lo que este denominador va a ser entonces,
"m" a la cuarta
multiplicado por
"x" al cubo elevado a la cuarta.
Lo único que estoy haciendo, es elevar "m" a la cuarta
y "x" al cubo elevarlo a la cuarta.
Y ahora,
¿cómo podemos simplificar esto?
El numerador es "m" a la sexta...
ese sigue siendo "m" a la sexta
dividido entre
"m" a la cuarta...
"m" a la cuarta, que multiplica a
"x" al cubo elevado a la cuarta.
Podemos aquí multiplicar los exponentes
para obtener "x" elevado a la 12...
"x" elevado a la 12.
Ahora, tenemos "m" a la sexta dividido entre "m" a la cuarta,
y esto lo puedes ver como,
"m" a la sexta por "m" a la -4,
ó podríamos hacer la simplificación,
pero nosotros sabemos...
espero que sepamos,
que esto de aquí,
este cociente de aquí, lo podemos simplificar como
"m" elevado a las 6 menos 4,
así es que esto es igual a
"m" al cuadrado,
esto es "m" a la 6 menos 4
y aún tenemos en el denominador "x" a la 12...
aún tenemos "x" a la 12,
así es que esto está dividido entre "x" a la 12
y ya hemos concluido.
Ahora, si no queremos tener
esta expresión en el denominador,
este "x" a la 12 del denominador,
podemos pasarlo al numerador como "x" a la -12,
esto sería igual entonces a "m" cuadrado
que ya tenemos
y este "x" a la 12, la podemos poner el numerador
como "x" a la -12.
Cualquiera de éstas dos es una respuesta válida.